your new book um it's called i tried to
change so you don't have to
why did you call it that because i
wanted a book
to inspire young women to let them know
i wish this was around when i was coming
up kelly i didn't have a book that i
could like
you know i thought that i had to be a
certain type of way or be
you know the way that people exactly
yeah so this book is a comedy book
it's an inspirational book it talks
about my upbringing in the detroit
and the brewster projects during the
crack era you know and how i avoided
that to become an engineer
how i quit that to now being on the
kelly clarkson
i mean your path is like so amazing just
those things you said the bullet points
are amazing
so you've also got a book about dating
advice so what was your worst date ever
i don't want to hear the good ones
okay yahoo gosh kelly there were so many
bad ones where really where should i
go um you know one time i went on a date
it was a first date
and he was trying to be fancy he got me
on a boat
and there was a lot of wind and the wig
blew off and
no and i was like and it was my good wig
it was like
my handmade good wig and i was like bruh
you got to go find my
and wig it was like laying on one of the
posts and we were able to retrieve it
but it was like yeah that one didn't
last too long
yeah oh my god that's about the worst
one yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help